sorry for starting the presentation with
the cough i think i still have a little
bit of a bug going around but now i want
to continue with the 45 45 90 triangles
so in the last presentation we learned
that
either side of a 45 45
90 triangle that isn't the hypotenuse is
equal to the square root of two
over two
times the hypotenuse
let's do a couple of more problems so if
i were to tell you
that the hypotenuse
of this triangle and it's a 45 once
again this only works for 45
45 90 triangles and if i just draw 145
you know the other angle's got to be 45
as well
if i told you that the hypotenuse here
is
let me say 10 all right we know this is
hypotenuse because it's opposite the
right angle
and then i would ask you what this side
is x well we know that x is equal to
square root of 2 over 2 times the
hypotenuse so that's square root of 2
over 2
times 10
or x is equal to
10 and whoops is equal to 5 square roots
of 2 right 10 divided by 2 so x is equal
to
5 square roots of 2. and we know that
this side and this side are equal
right i guess we know it's an isosceles
triangle because these two angles are
the same so we also know that this side
is 5
over 2. and if you're not sure
try it out let's try the pythagorean
theorem we know from the pythagorean
theorem that 5 root 2
squared
plus 5
root 2
squared is equal to the hypotenuse
squared the hypotenuse is 10
is equal to 100
well this is just 25 times 2 so that's
plus 25 times 2 is 50.
this is 100 up here is equal to 100
and we know of course that this is true
so it worked we proved it using the
pythagorean theorem and that's how
actually we came up with this formula in
the first place
maybe you want to go back to one of
those presentations if you forget how we
came up with this
i'm actually now going to introduce
another type of triangle and i'm going
to do it the same way by
just
posing a problem to you and then
using
the pythagorean theorem to figure it out
this is another type of triangle called
a 30 60 90 triangle
90 triangle if i don't have time for
this i will do another presentation
let's say i have
a right triangle
that's not a pretty one but
we'll use what we have
that's a right angle and if i were told
you
tell you that this is a 30 degree angle
well we know that the angles in a
triangle have to add up to 180. so this
is 30 this is 90 and let's say that this
is x
x plus 30
plus 90 is equal to 180 because the
angles in a triangle add up to 180 we
know that x is equal to 60
right so this angle is 60.
and this is why it's called a 30 69
triangle
because that's the names of the three
angles in the triangle
and
if i were to tell you that the
hypotenuse is let's say the hypotenuse
of this triangle let me instead of
calling it c like we always do let's
call it h
and i want to figure out the other sides
how do we do that well we can do that
using pretty much the pythagorean
theorem
and here i'm going to do a little trick
let's draw another
copy of this triangle but draw it
exactly
flip it over drawing it draw it the
other
side and this is the same triangle it's
just facing the other direction right if
this is 90 degrees we know these two
angles are supplementary you might want
to review the angles module if you
forget that
two angles that share kind of this
common line would add up to 180 degrees
if this is 90 this will also be 90 and
you could eyeball it it makes sense
and since we flipped it this triangle is
the exact same triangle as this it's
just flipped over to the other side
we also know that this angle is 30
degrees
and we also know that this angle
is 60 degrees
right
well if this angle is 30 degrees and
this angle is 30 degrees we also know
that this larger angle
goes all the way from here to here is 60
degrees
right
well if this angle is 60 degrees this
top angle is 60 degrees and this angle
on the right is 60 degrees
then we know well we know
that we know from the theorem that we
learned when we did 45 45 90 triangles
that if these two angles are the same
then the sides that they don't share
have to be
the same as well so what are the size
they don't share well
it's this side and this side so this
side is h
then this side is h right
but this angle is also 60 degrees
so if we look at this 60 degrees and
this 60 degrees
we know that the sides that they don't
share
are also equal well they share this side
so the sides that they don't share are
this side and this side so this side is
h we also know that this side is h
right
so it turns out that if you have 60
degrees 60 degrees and 60 degrees that
all the sides are the same length or
it's an equilateral triangle and that's
something something to keep in mind and
that makes sense too because an
equilateral triangle is symmetric no
matter how you look at it so it makes
sense that all the angles would be the
same and all of the sides would have the
same length
but
when we when we originally did this
problem we only used half of this
equilateral triangle so we know this
whole
side right here is of length h
but if that whole side is of length h
well then
this side right here just the base of
our original triangle and i'm trying to
be messy on purpose
let me try another color
this is going to be half of that side
right
because that's h of
and then this is also h over 2 right
over here
h over 2.
so if we go back to our original
triangle and we said this is 30 degrees
and that this is the hypotenuse because
it's opposite the right angle we know
that the side
opposite the 30 degree side is half of
the hypotenuse
and just a reminder how did we do that
well we doubled the triangle turned into
an equilateral triangle figured out this
whole side has to be the same as
hypotenuse
and this is half of that whole side so
it's half of the hypotenuse so let's
remember that the side opposite the 30
degree side is half of the hypotenuse
let me redraw that on another
page because i think this is getting
messy so going back to what i had
originally
this is a right angle
this is the hypotenuse this side right
here
if this is 30 degrees we just derived
that the side opposite the 30 degrees
the side opposite right it's like what
what the angle is opening into that this
is equal to one half the hypotenuse
if this is equal to one half the
hypotenuse then what is this side equal
to
well here we can use the pythagorean
theorem again
we know that this side squared plus this
side squared let's call this side a
is equal to eight squared
so we have one half
whoops one half h
squared
plus a squared is equal to h squared
this is equal to h squared
over 4
plus a squared is equal to h squared
well we subtract h squared from both
sides we get a squared
is equal to h squared minus h squared
over 4.
so this equals
h squared times 1 minus 1 4.
this is equal to 3 4
h squared
excuse the cough and once again that's
equal to a squared
i'm running out of space so i'm going to
go all the way over here
so take the square root of both sides
and we get
a
is equal to
the square root of three fourths is the
same thing as the square root of three
over two
and then the square root of h is of h
squared is just h
and this a remember this is an area this
is what we decided the length of the
side i probably shouldn't have used a
but this is equal to the square root of
over 2
times h
so with there we've derived what all the
sides relative to the hypotenuse are of
a 30-60-90 triangle so this is a
60-degree side
so if we know the hypotenuse
and we know this is a 30-16-90 triangle
we know the side opposite the 30 degree
side is one half the hypotenuse
and we know the side opposite the 60
degree side
is the square root of 3
over 2 times the hypotenuse
in the next module i'll show you how
using this information which you may or
may not want to memorize is probably
good to memorize and practice with
because it'll make you very fast on
standardized tests
how we can use this information to to
solve the size of a 30-60-90 triangle
very quickly see you in the next
presentation